Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2192.
David P Here is a really great question about
how to deal with people who do a certain really
annoying thing during political debates, in
conversations.
Take a listen.
Speaker 6: Hey, David.
Sir, this is Jose.
I just had a quick question.
Yes.
I was wondering if you had any advice to what
you would tell somebody to having a discussion
with them about politics, where they just
immediately go to what about Islam?
They don't really bring anything to the conversation.
They just say, what about this?
What about that?
What about this?
Yeah, this needs some help just with that.
Speaker 1: Thank you.
So this is super common.
The way it might go is you say, listen, the
evidence is indicative that Trump committed
crimes and should be charged.
And then the person you're talking to goes,
well, what about Hunter Biden?
Understand that sometimes when people do the
what about this other thing, it's because
their brain is scrambled.
And I'm not saying this to make fun of people,
but what I mean is there are lots of people
who they don't organize their thoughts in
their head and they can't think straight.
And so they're just bouncing all over the
place.
And it's sort of like a cognitive issue of
getting them to actually focus in on.
The one thing you're trying to talk about,
that's one category.
You then also have people who use what about
ism as deliberate deception or to try to undermine
or distract and create red herrings.
They use it sort of like as a tool, very deliberately
and in bad faith.
And then you've got people who it's not that
their brain is totally scrambled and they're
not completely bad faith.
They're just kind of like a little ignorant
and they don't realize that there's all these
separate issues and we should deal with these
issues one at a time.
So the step one is sort of try to figure out
if the person doing the whataboutism is doing
it for one or the other of those possibilities
that I mentioned, bad faith, brain scrambled,
sort of confused.
Try to figure that out.
And one of the best tools that I find when
somebody brings out this other thing that
they want to talk about is to say, hey, you
know what?
That may also be a problem.
I'm glad to talk about that.
But let's stick with this topic first.
Resolve it and then we can talk about that
other thing very quickly.
You'll know if you say something like that
when the what about ism pops up, whether you're
dealing with a brain scramble or someone functioning
in bad faith or someone who's just a little
bit confused, and sometimes they'll say, Oh,
you know what?
You're right.
Okay, yeah, let's figure this thing out first.
Then we can talk about that other thing, another
tool.
These aren't even really tools.
These are literally just one liners to try
to refocus the conversation.
Another thing that can sometimes be said when
the whataboutism pops up is something along
the lines of Can we just decide and agree
what we're talking about now?
I know there is all.
These different things we can talk about.
You're wanting to talk about something different.
Let's just agree what we're now talking about.
And oftentimes it'll get the other person
to have to actually tell you what it is we're
talking about.
And if they're doing a what about ism with
something that really isn't related?
But what about that time when Obama drew a
red line in Syria?
Doesn't really have anything to do with the
Qatari World Cup, does it?
Right.
The example sometimes that will also get people
refocus because you're letting them decide
what you're talking about.
And sometimes it'll become evident that the
two things aren't related.
If you're trying to talk about criminal charges
against Trump and they want to talk about
Obama's red line, and you say, can you just
tell me what are we talking about right now?
Just so we can finish that, it's going to
be hard for them to go.
Well, we're talking about criminal charges
against Trump and Obama's red line in Syria.
A lot of people, when they say that out loud,
would go, wait a second, that those two things
aren't even remotely connected.
That doesn't make any sense.
Okay.
So some ideas for dealing with the what about
lists?
Friday, December 23rd.
We are doing a one day membership special,
hugely discounted last one of the year.
Remember, we're an independent media show
and we're funded by our viewers, but we're
going to do something extra.
We are going to donate your first month's
discounted payment.
When you sign up Friday with a coupon code
that is forthcoming, we will donate that first
month's payment to charity to be sent as cash
to people in need.
I'm talking about people for whom a few bucks
makes a big difference.
People living on a dollar a day, people living
on $2 a day in different parts of the world.
We've never done this before and we have an
up to $15,000 match.
So if you have a $6 a month membership coupon
code smacks it down to $3 a month.
We will donate your $3 and we will match it
with another $3.
We've never tried this.
We're trying to do something for the people.
If you want to be notified about this, it'll
be in an email that goes out Friday morning.
Get on my newsletter at David Pakman dot com.
It's free to get on it.
You just type in your email address at the
top right of the page, and Friday you will
get all of the details on today's bonus show.
The Ukrainian president, Volodymyr Zelensky,
is coming to the U.S. He may already be here.
He will be addressing Congress tonight.
It is a big deal when a foreign leader addresses
Congress.
We will talk about it.
Elon Musk will resign as head of Twitter.
And many of you wrote to me and said, this
is great news.
A few of you wrote to me and said, this is
bad news.
They're going to install a flunky.
He'll do all the same terrible things.
And then Elon Musk can say, I'm not even in
charge anymore and shift blame.
We'll talk about it.
And we are also going to talk about the confusion
and the falsehoods that have been spreading
in China as China has reversed its so-called
zero-covid policy, which, of course, didn't
really lead to zero COVID.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show.
Signup at join PACOM.
We will see you then.